they make it their business to mind your
business under new ordinance who studied
and suspected of hoarding can get visits
from cops and $500 gate fines in an
upstate New York an officer took you to
Jason Doolin for vaping while driving
never mind that nice digs produced no
flame Arash and there isn't even a law
against enjoin old school smokes behind
the wheel brings out the cop side of the
law that forbids driving while using
portable electronic devices even though
II cigarettes aren't among the forbidden
devices but this time we zero in on
Arizona where a state senator is
targeting home births but love to
preserve the choice of the mother for
their home birth but that child also
needs to have a choice
the choice not to die so says senator
Kelli Ward who is also a family
physician she's authored a bill that
would forbid an expectant mother from
giving birth at home with the help of a
licensed Midwife that the baby was in a
breech position or if the woman had
previously given birth via a cesarean
section but hospital births are not
significantly safer than home births
according to the president of the
midwives alliance of North America who
says that more and more states are
trying to restrict home births and maybe
the bigger issues whether it's wise to
politicize home births rather than
having parents weigh the pros and cons
themselves follow the show on Twitter
submit your nanny nominees and check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business